vor einigen Tagen startete der erste
kommerzielle Weltraumflug von Virgin
Galactic ihren Weg ins All an Bord der
Galaktik 01 3 Mitglieder der
italienischen Luftwaffe und des
nationalen forschungsrats die einige
Experimente durchgeführt haben der Flug
dauerte etwa 90 Minuten lang dafür wird
die Rakete in der Luft vom
Trägerflugzeug abgekoppelt und fliegt
dann mit eigenem Antrieb auf etwas über
80 km Höhe nach ein paar Minuten
Schwerelosigkeit geht der Kurs zurück
Richtung Erde ab August will die Firma
des britischen Milliardärs Richard
Branson dann monatlich Touristen und
weitere Forschungsteams ins Weltall
schicken seine Mission
stellt euch eine Welt vor in der
Menschen allen Alters mit allen
Hintergründen und egal welchen
Geschlechts oder welcher Ethnie den
gleichen Zugang zum Weltall haben
noch scheint dieses Ziel weit entfernt
die Tickets werden aktuell für rund
450.000 US-Dollar angeboten 800 davon
sein bereits verkauft worden Branson
selbst flog bei einem der letzten
Testflüge 2021 mit seiner Rakete ins All
an die nächste Generation von Träumern
wenn wir das hier schaffen können stellt
euch nur vor was ihr alles erreichen
könnt
damit habe er sich seinen Kindheitstraum
erfüllt und gleichzeitig den
Konkurrenten basos im Wettrennen um
knapp neun Tage geschlagen seitdem hängt
er hinterher sowohl Elon Musk als auch
Jeff Bezos schicken mit ihren
Unternehmen SpaceX und Blue Origin
bereits Touristen ins All doch der
extrem-tourismus hat seinen Preis bei
der Entwicklung der Galaktik 01 starben
insgesamt vier Menschen einmal
explodierte ein Treibstofftank ein
anderes Mal brach die Rakete in zwei das
Problem seinen fehlende Regulationen
mein Teresa Pulver
vielleicht hätte das verhindert werden
können hätte sich ein unabhängiger
Experte die Konstruktion angesehen und
gesagt dass so ein sicherheitskritischer
Mechanismus nicht bei einem einzigen
menschlichen Fehler Versagen darf
ein Vergleich zu dem U-Boot Unglück der
Titan liegt nahe auch hier Regulationen
Fehlanzeige dafür wie es auch im
privaten Bereich mit Regulationen besser
gehen könnte sei SpaceX ein gutes
Beispiel
[Musik]
hat ihre raketentechnologien zusammen
mit der Nase entwickelt dadurch mussten
sie all ihre Sicherheitsanforderungen
erfüllen weil die NASA ihre Astronauten
in keine Raumkapsel stecken würde die
nicht vorher überprüft wurde
die Raketen von spaceex beliefern schon
seit einiger Zeit die Internationale
Raumstation auch die nächste Mondmission
soll in einer ihrer Raketen stattfinden
die Zusammenarbeit von öffentlichen und
privaten Institutionen soll in Zukunft
noch weiter ausgebaut werden
absolut die staatlich privaten
Partnerschaften gehen weiter die
Regierungen sind sehr engagiert die NASA
in den Vereinigten Staaten die ESA in
Europa und nun kommen immer mehr private
Unternehmen dazu da ist einiges in
Bewegung wir sehen einen neuen
Wirtschaftszweig die weltraumwirtschaft
die NASA will die Internationale
Raumstation 2030 verlassen sie arbeitet
deswegen jetzt schon mit einigen
privaten Unternehmen zusammen die
kommerzielle Weltraumstation bauen und
leiten sollen die Nase selbst will darin
dann nur noch einen gewissen Bereich
mieten kritiker sehen dabei aber auch
ein Problem nämlich dann wenn die Firmen
ihren Profit in den Vordergrund rücken
und nicht den Fortschritt der
Wissenschaft ein noch größerer
Kritikpunkt beim Ausbau des
kommerziellen weltraumgeschäfts die
Auswirkungen auf das Klima die
raketentreibstoffe stoßen jede Menge
Emissionen teilweise direkt in die obere
Atmosphäre aus dort sind diese noch viel
schädlicher als unten auf der Erde und
halten sich mehrere Jahre lang aktuell
an die Unternehmen planen in der Zukunft
jeden Tag zu starten das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht morgen oder in
einem Jahr zu Problemen führen aber in
50 oder 100 Jahren wird sich plötzlich
eine Menge Schadstoffe in der höheren
Atmosphäre angesammelt haben und dort
gibt es keine Möglichkeit diese wieder
zu entfernen
einige Unternehmen bemühen sich den Flug
ins All nachhaltiger zu gestalten indem
sie wieder verwendbare Raketen oder
umweltfreundlichere Treibstoffe
verwenden auch das in Teilen um
kosteneffizienter zu arbeiten die
Kommerzialisierung ist in vollem Gange
und nicht mehr aufzuhalten und konkrete
Bereiche und Aufteilungen zu haben
könnte die Kooperation in Zukunft so
aussehen
die Regierungen werden weiterhin die
Erkundung und die wissenschaftliche
Forschung finanzieren während die
Privatunternehmen mehr an den
Geschäftsmöglichkeiten interessiert sein
werden wahrscheinlich in der niedrigeren
Erdumlaufbahn um dort Dinge zu tun wie
Produktion vielleicht für
pharmazeutische Zwecke aber auf jeden
Fall mehr wirtschaftsbezogen und dann
natürlich der Tourismus
private Unternehmen bleiben auf den
Raumstationen und Touristen Fliegen zu
Grenze des Weltraums
zumindest die die es sich leisten können